aujourd'hui on est en train de
redécouvrir que les femmes sont des
êtres humains et que c'est une femme
c'est pas un trou par lequel le sexe
d'un homme entre et par où les enfants
sorte que les femmes c'est aussi autre
chose
[Musique]
au conseil des ministres du 26 mai 1976
la journaliste et écrivaine françoise
giroud alors secrétaire d'état chargé de
la condition féminine présente sans une
mesure en faveur de l'autonomie et des
droits des femmes
ce projet de 32 pages le voici pour ceux
qui n'ont pas encore la télévision
couleur je précise qu'il est de couleur
orange afin de changer les lois en
profondeur ces mesures prennent en
compte l'ensemble des aspects de la vie
d'une femme de son plus jeune âge à sa
retraite
l'idée c'est de mettre au point une
politique qui aura pour effet de changer
la vie de toutes les femmes françaises
sans pour autant ôter quoi que ce soit
aux hommes savez je suis je suis pour
l'équivalence entre les hommes et les
femmes et pas du tout pour le martyre
des hommes simplement pas pour le
martyre des femmes non plus françoise
giroud présente la liste des réformes à
accomplir en cinq ans destiné à
atteindre ce qu'elle appelle
l'équivalence social alors en gros dans
cinq ans si la situation de la france
est bonne bonne pour tout le monde si
elle est mauvaise tout ce que je demande
c'est qu'elle ne soit pas plus mauvaise
pour les femmes que pour les hommes le
but de ces mesures est la reconnaissance
par la société d'une valeur égale et le
libre exercice de droits et de devoirs
égaux et si tout ça semble clair
aujourd'hui dans les années 70 c'était
plus compliqué
les mentalités c'est naturellement ce
qu'il ya de plus difficile surtout sur
un sujet pareil y compris les mentalités
des ministres avec les qualifs adecco
d'abord et pour pouvoir changer les lois
laissant une mesure ont été
minutieusement préparée avec l'ensemble
des ministères concernés de l'éducation
au travail de la santé aux finances et
de la justice à l'intérieur tout ça a
été étudiée ministère par ministère tous
a été chiffré il ya des choses qui
coûtent très cher il y en a d'autres qui
ne coûte pas d'argent et tout ça a été
acceptée par les ministres intéressés
et voici le plan d'attac éducation et
formation des jeunes filles définition
par un nouveau régime matrimonial légal
des nouvelles responsabilités des jeunes
femmes révision de l'ensemble des
conditions de travail et des freins à la
promotion et à l'égalité des salaires
mais aussi des mesures visant à
faciliter la maternité pour celles qui
le désirent nouvelles conditions du
partage des tâches parentales et
domestiques extension de la prise de
responsabilité sociale des femmes par
une ouverture plus grande des portes de
la vie politique et administre
steve ou encore institutions de divers
systèmes d'assurance obligatoire
couvrant aussi bien le loyer que le
décès du chef de famille et contribuer
ainsi à combler les failles et les
insuffisances du système actuel de
protection sociale une autre mesure
consiste à protéger les femmes qui ont
plus de 55 ans enfin françoise giroud
propose une loi générale qui devrait
permettre de sanctionner toutes les
dispositions juridiques discriminatoires
pour ça elle s'avère conciliante et us
d'une grande diplomatie démonstration il
s'agit en somme de définir une politique
pour les femmes qui soit à la fois
respectueux des traditions françaises
parce qu'il ya des choses qui sont
bonnes toujours dans les traditions et
qui en même temps tiennent compte
véritablement des aspirations et des
besoins des jeunes femmes respect des
traditions pour ne pas voir des nuées de
conservateurs se braquer contre les
mesures et accent sur la jeunesse mais
malgré ces efforts les sens une mesure
et françoise giroud trouve tout de même
quelques ennemis je serai très ennuyé si
je n'avais pas d'ennemis ce serait
mauvais ceni mais pour un changement en
profondeur père est né viable il faut un
éveil des consciences des hommes comme
des femmes
je crois que tout ça a commencé à
héberger la conscience masculine et ceux
qui a hébergé aussi et dans la
conscience féminine bien sûr et ceux qui
a hébergé c'est l'idée très importante
que les femmes sont des êtres humains
des relativement neuf
elle est linguiste et pendant longtemps
mais elle a disparu au 19e siècle en
france en deux cordes d'ailleurs
l'éducation des enfants fait également
partie du projet et là encore elle va
faire appel à l'histoire pour établir
des principes fondamentaux
ils ont qu'il ya une certaine idée de la
division du travail quitte une idée
relativement récente qui est une idée
qui est née dans la société industrielle
la femme et à la main
s'occupe des enfants et l'homme gagne de
l'argent de l'or et le ramène à la
maison et on a complètement déserté la
vieille idée selon laquelle l'homme et
la femme vivait ensemble et s'occuper
ensemble des enfants et je souhaiterais
beaucoup que cette liste soit ranimer et
parmi ces mesures elle entend également
lutter contre le sexisme dans la
fonction publique dans la fonction
publique ondine opté pour la des
critères n'est ce pas on dit épaules ils
arrivent à l'heure eh bien je voudrais
que dans ses notes interviennent un
critère qui est celui du comportement à
l'égard du personnel de l'autre sexe
ce sera très important trésor mais
réforme s'applique aussi bien dans le
domaine professionnel que dans l'espace
public et je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez l'histoire des chasseurs et
du lièvre pour moi la situation se
présente ainsi il ya toujours eu des
chasseurs les avons chassés les femmes
et de même il ya des chasseurs qui vont
dans la forêt et qui chasse les lièvres
tu as fait normal imaginez que
brusquement des lièvres lui de courir se
retourne et dire mieux ceci vous
continuez j'appelle mon avocat mais
c'est ça la situation est alors les
chasseurs 10 mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça avait de quoi se mêlent mails
sont insupportables font foi les femmes
mais c'est le lièvre qui va provoquer ci
avait pas de lier avant dans la forêt
mais je ne tirerai pas dessus sur les
sens une mesure initialement proposé 80
sont acceptés ce qui ne signifie pas que
chacune fait l'objet d'une loi
l'époque où les mesures sont adoptées
fait que d'autres lois devront s'y
ajouter ultérieurement pour s'adapter
aux besoins sociétaux et aux évolutions
du monde du travail
c'est une tentative d'éliminer toutes
les discriminations qui existe entre les
femmes et les hommes
ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles seront
toutes éliminées il reste des injustices
bien sûr mais enfin je suis là pour
essayer de les réparer et comme elle
l'écrit vie si les femmes ne sont pas
encore ce qu'elles seront ni ce qu'elle
voudrait être
elles ne seront plus jamais ce qu'elle
était
[Musique]